la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
un oasis de nature cultivés dans un
océan de verdure
c'est à saint philippe au pied du volcan
que benoît morel a mis en valeur ses
huit hectares de terrain vanille
palmistes et quantité d'arbres fruitiers
post ici tranquillement au rythme des
saisons
car dame nature est là aussi chez elle
vénéré respecter parce travailleurs de
la terre qui a choisi depuis plusieurs
années de se lancer dans l'agriculture
biologique
bien sûr j'ai toujours été attiré par ce
côté un peu plus naturel et j'ai fait
j'ai rencontré des personnes
intéressantes sur mon parcours et ça m'a
donné l'impulsion justement d'aller vers
cette agriculture non pas seulement deux
pour le côté économique mais c'est plus
par éthique c'est à dire donner un sens
à ma vie d'agriculteur et ne pas être
dépendant justement des arbres aux
chimistes et travailler vraiment avec la
nature et pour le consommateur c'est à
dire essayer de produire quelque chose
de sain et pour moi même pour ma famille
pour les autres les pesticides chimiques
sont ici bien entendu banni pour lutter
contre les ravageurs de ces vanier
benoît utilisent des produits naturels
tout aussi efficace dans certains cas
sinon au niveau de certaines maladies
comme les poux bien leurs films à jean
et cochonou tout ça
l'ancien traitements naturels à base
d'huile ou de savon ou simplement du de
colza de nature elle pas tout simplement
et c'est sa technique et qui est
pratique et qui est très très très
efficace pas la peine de chercher des
pesticides on n'a pas besoin culture
emblématique de saint philippe
la vanille et le palmiste post ici en
symbiose les pieds de palmiste rouge au
front en effet ou vanniers l'ombre âge
ainsi que tous les éléments nécessaires
à leur développement
à presque arrêtée ce que vain ses
failles suffit à lui-même pour le
nourrir et
nourrir la vanille donc au niveau là
pour ramasser organique c'est suffisant
c'est une pareille qui se décomposait
que le temps donc pour la vanille super
intéressant et il n'a pas d'activité
comme certains comme le cocotier par
exemple comme certaines espèces de
vanille donc un excellent tuteur est là
donc c'est des palmistes réserver
uniquement pour la vanille et bien sûr
même comme je suis pas du tout parmi
ceux-là mais aussi de récolter les
graines toile et semi benoît morel
replante ainsi régulièrement de
nouvelles parcelles en palmiste rouge
l'une des variétés la plus appréciée des
consommateurs les choux de palmiste bio
qu'ils récoltent meilleurs stades
après plusieurs années de croissance
alors déjà ouvre un sas est un
fournisseur bien certain volume des gens
et sa canne taille dont l'ancien parmi
ceux qui avaient été plantés ya environ
quatre ans qu'il quasiment cinq ans et
puis la graine et voilà arrivés à bon
stade peut être récolté bien sûr
notamment j'avais aussi couilles n'est
pas obligé de manger avec la vinaigrette
coiffer soit on peut le manger cru et et
c'est aussi bon qu'une simple salade
donc une culture qui est qui s'y prête à
saint-philippe et qui est une culture
encore rentable qui en compterait
demander
agriculteur bio à saint philippe benoît
morel cultive sur près de 8 hectares un
véritable jardin d'éden
tout ou presque tous ici de manière
naturelle
comme ces parcelles de curcuma comme on
a toujours été un peu attiré par cette
fin deux camarades épices et c'est une
culture en fête qui s'y prête quand même
assez bien au niveau de saint philippe à
nos régions et puis en plus c'est une
culture une épice qui est très demandé
en ce moment au niveau
comment dire vas-tu médicinales donc et
puis en bio quoi donc il ya quand même
de la demande et sur moi comme je suis
en bio moi j'ai eu l'opportunité le
monde essaie de mettre en place un pc
culturel à développer quoi à côté de ces
cultures traditionnelles
benoît a également planter des essences
endémique ainsi que de nombreux arbres
fruitiers exotiques originaires des
quatre coins du monde
cosy aubaine choisi des andes ou
paiement jalu comme ça c'est ça dans les
croquants et même avec le noyau a
carrément une un goût de noisette et
enfin contre caen dimanche joli collier
mieux mais c'est là la chaire eux sur le
noyau fait un décret me et 1 à goutte
d'eau
baby star du barreau de noisettes en
fait de cacahuètes de pistaches
au détour du chemin benoît nous fait
découvrir un autre fruit tout aussi
méconnu sur notre île mais qui existe à
la réunion depuis un certain temps 1 et
qui s'appelle le chic où on fait un
anglais mais c'est l'as à petit en fait
la vraie ça petit et ça petit y est
voilà donc c'est un fluide originaire
des caraïbes et d'amérique centrale et
bien qui n'a pas été pareil a introduit
la réunion mais qui n'a jamais été
développé et l'a donc moi j'étais un
petit peu aussi pas cette culture qui
fait partie d'une diversité de fruits
sains donc que le créole connais pas
trop il connaît pas encore et peut-être
un plus tôt dans quelques années vous il
va découvrir il va peut-être apprécié
parce que c'est un fruit quand même qui
est très sucrée mais toutes les bonnes
choses ont une fin
la visite passionnante de l'exploitation
s'achève avec au passage une dégustation
d'eau de coco très rafraîchissante et
parfois piller les pipettes faire avec
si les commandes est allé good sont le
japon didier sur les hommes et associés
noix de coco un sens et une production /
exploitation pour moi il fait partie de
non seulement la beauté mais aussi un
peu d'équilibré et ben c'est un fruit
quand il fait chaud les cons avec des
haltères et il est agréable corps comme
dirait monsieur morel il ya tous les
éléments qu'il faut pour nourrir l'homme
et voilà donc il a pas besoin cheikh
saoud les good sont toutefois de lui
quand il travaille est ici fait
suffisamment chaud pour autant il faut
le sabre bâton
et toi
don